[Music]
all right what's up guys i'm pbhd here
and welcome to a new video series idea
here's how this one goes so we pick a
category on amazon probably somewhere in
tech and we find the number one
best-selling item in that category on
all of amazon
and buy it and give it a shot see if
it's actually worth it i don't really
have a name for this yet maybe we could
come up with a name if there's some sort
of clever comment i might use that but
as of right now that's the general idea
so category number one for the initial
episode is naturally smartphones on
amazon there's a category under
electronics called unlocked cell phones
and the number one best-selling item
sitting at the top pretty much since it
came out
is this the moto g6 so this is a 250
smartphone uh maybe even a little bit
less than this right now on amazon but
that makes it definitely falling in the
budget category and i definitely tend to
focus most of my smartphone videos on
flagships the the phones i'm most
usually spending time with but we've
definitely covered mid-range and budget
stuff in the past and with budget stuff
like this it's really all about where
you save your money where you
strategically bring some stuff up from
flagships from 900 phones and where you
don't and so on moto g6 when you look at
it it has a couple things that it brings
up from today's flagships but it still
saves money in a lot of the places where
you might not say it's worth it it's a
well-balanced checklist so they brought
up the 18 by nine aspect ratio for
example on the display they brought up
the glass back they brought up dual
cameras usbc but they didn't bring up a
notch they didn't cut the headphone jack
they didn't shrink the bezels to be tiny
so there are trade-offs so i won't put
these amazon videos in the same category
as like a full review which are much
more detailed but for these quick little
device expose we're going to focus on
the good the okay
and the bad and if there is any the ugly
but basically figure out why this thing
sits at the top of the charts and see if
it's actually worth it so the good you
can start off with the display here so
moto g has actually kind of always been
leading budget smartphones since the
beginning of the series but this is the
first moto g with an eighteen by nine
display instead of sixteen by nine so
basically it's bigger and it's
definitely taller but it's only one or
two millimeters wider so you get much
more screen in not much more phone it's
a 5.7 inch 1080p lcd panel it's not
blowing anyone's pants off of course in
terms of brightness or colors like some
oleds would but it's otherwise pretty
good especially for the price gets just
bright enough to not be a problem and
it's still coming in at over 420 pixels
per inch so it's plenty sharp too so
even if you see 1080p and think it's low
it's not and just generally as a pixel
person i'm happy to see them take care
to not have a garbage display and then
there's the design which is also good
this is the sleekest most premium
looking moto g yet you might even
remember in previous years of the
smartphone awards the moto g has been
this defending champ in the best budget
phones category and these phones have
always been rubberized or plastic or
hard in plastic never like this never
with this glass the rounded corners
tapered edges gets these clicky tactile
buttons i'll have more to say on this
all later but this is a well-built phone
for 250 bucks and then also under the
good is the software and this is
something that motorola has excelled in
in the past with past moto g's and other
past phones and they do it again here in
a lot of the same ways but with one
major exception and i'll explain so this
phone has near stock android and i talk
about this all the time with just a
couple of additions on top of it and i
really like that it's something i've
praised for years especially with past
motorola phones and they've built in
features like moto display which shows
your notifications in like this
non-obtrusive way unless you interact
with them even while the screen is
mostly off even though it's not an oled
there's moto actions which have been
classic for a while the chop chop of
your phone to turn the flashlight on or
the double twist to open the camera
stuff like that and it's all built into
one place but everything else for the
most part here is pretty tame pretty
functional nothing too flashy uh now
since it is an amazon special it has a
bunch of these pre-installed amazon apps
amazon drive amazon's kindle app their
amazon music and even alexa actually
front and center i don't use any of
these and they're not uninstallable but
if you get a custom launcher you can
just kind of hide them the fingerprint
reader can lock the phone and unlock the
phone you can turn on one button mode
which lets you use the single slightly
shrunken fingerprint reader as a gesture
pad to do swiping to go home and back
and all that stuff but that's pretty
much it no crazy stylus features the
face unlock is super basic there's no
squeeze function no crazy fake buttons
no edge screen
it's clean near stock android the way a
lot of people including me like it but
the one caveat i mentioned earlier uh
usually near stock android means easier
software updates down the road so if you
have near stock it's usually just a
couple weeks behind like the pure stock
android devices but with motorola lately
that's not been the case and they've
been lagging behind slacking pretty hard
on software updates sometimes not
updating phones at all so i would say
sadly don't buy this phone if you're
expecting a long tail of software
updates and security patches that just
doesn't seem like something motorola's
into right now and i'm like basically
calling them out like they should change
that but as of right now i can't say
that this phone will get that anyway
that brings us to the okay you know
there's like i said there's not a lot of
stuff you can bring from a 900 flagship
down into this price point but doesn't
mean they're bad you know there's things
that are just middle of the road okay on
this phone there's no ip certification
for water resistance but motorola calls
it splash proof so you know some people
who are clumsier than others might not
want to take the risk with this one
but what's probably more important here
is the glass back but also no wireless
charging and the glass is still kind of
nice don't get me wrong it's solid it
feels good it's a little heavier it's
premium in the hand with the tapered
edges but obviously now a fingerprint
magnet and much more fragile i feel like
the moto g series is one that could have
totally stayed away from the glass trend
and been fine like they've done it with
more expensive phones in the past but
they just went to glass here now the
specs are okay so uh snapdragon 415
mid-range chip three gigabytes of rams
pretty good uh 32 gigs of storage to
start and a 3000 milliamp hour battery
which has been holding up just fine
especially thanks to the 1080p display
but the standby time is not all that
great so i guess use it to get the most
out of it it has a headphone jack that's
good for a lot of people that's actually
great in 2018
and the fingerprint reader it's it's
kind of sad that motorola felt the need
to put their logo on the front of the
phone so bad that they literally shoved
it in between the fingerprint reader and
the screen i will never not hate logos
on the front of phones and this makes it
look like they cut down on the size of
the fingerprint reader to make room for
a logo i hope that's not what happened
and the cameras on the back there's a 12
megapixel camera with a 5 megapixel
secondary shooter it looks like a face
no way around that it's totally a face
and it's funny the photos it takes are
decent at best the dynamic range is one
thing that's particularly weak
but the detail holds up if you don't
zoom in and pixel peep too much
basically if a 900 phone was taking
these photos i'd be calling it a little
weak but in a super inexpensive phone
like this it definitely gets the job
done with no problems and then of course
you got to ask if there's anything
bad anything truly bad about this phone
and honestly
the standby time is pretty bad i've had
it die just by going from 50 to zero
overnight there's not anything crazy
going on with the software it's just
pretty weak
and maybe aside from the the poor track
record with software updates there's
nothing truly horrific about the moto g6
even like the usual suspects you'd look
for to be garbage in a cheap phone uh
the front-facing camera still actually
not that bad the vibration motor totally
average the speaker if you notice
there's no speaker on the bottom where
you usually find the crappy ones there
here it's actually just the front-facing
earpiece as the only speaker on this
phone technically it is just one source
so it's easy to completely block but
you'll never really hold your phone
accidentally in a way to block it and
the fact that it's front-facing means it
sounds better and louder than pretty
much any other downward-facing speaker
so for 250 bucks i mean what it really
comes down to is this phone gets the job
done with no
major glaring flaws so it's probably not
really a surprise that this is really
cheap making it the number one
best-selling phone on amazon right now i
feel like i could probably carry this
phone daily the big complaints i would
have would be the camera because i'm a
big camera person and probably the
speaker i'm really used to front-facing
really good speakers
but the screen is okay like it's fine it
gets the job done i think what's more
interesting is i don't know if this is
clearly the budget king like it has been
in previous years there's plenty of
other manufacturers actually now really
focusing on this price point things like
nokia things like xiaomi things like
redmi just to name a few so you can't
call this the budget king quite like it
was separating itself from the pack
before
but it's still pretty good so if you
were browsing amazon just wondering why
the g6 was the number one best-selling
unlocked cell phone or if you were just
wondering you should buy this phone or
not gets a thumbs up from me it's pretty
good
either way let me know what you guys
think if this series idea is something
you'd be into maybe leave suggestions
for other categories on amazon to pick
up and check out the number one product
for
but until the next one thanks for
watching
peace